so the iPad is finally here and if
you're not really sure what to do with
it here are five applications that I
found that I think would be pretty fun
so the first one is flight control a
game I've been dying to play on the iPad
because it was such a great game on the
iPhone it just involves you trolling
twirling around your fingers to land
airplanes and prevent them from crashing
into each other so it's really cool
because it really uses a touchscreen
really nice way to draw a path and you
can draw a really really detailed path
to to land the planes so the game gets
harder and harder more and more planes
come bigger planes come and the goal is
to just land as many planes as you can
before one of them crashes into another
if it just died and the next one I want
to show you is called beautiful planet
HD a two traveling journalist went all
over the world took some photos and
wrote some passages about their various
photographs and this is like a really
neat way presented so they had this
illustrative or this interactive map you
could tap on a country they visited and
see all the pictures they took you can
see it as a slideshow if you want you
could also read whatever they wrote for
each photo and I think this is just a
really neat way to rethink the traveling
journal
the iPhone has some really neat musical
instrument applications and people are
playing with them very experimental ways
but I think the lack of the lack of
screen size really made it limited in
terms of what you could do so I think
the iPad is going to be a really
interesting platform for musical
instruments it's going to be really neat
here's another one I really really like
it's called marble I'm sure everybody's
gonna get this one is free and it just
sells you Marvel comic books but more
importantly it displays them in a new
way which I really really like the way
they display these comics just looks
really amazing I just it looks better
than paper to me really and what's more
important is that you can DoubleTap on a
single frame and you can start viewing
each frame one by one it's almost like
it's a movie at that point
so the last one I want to show you is
pretty simple with just a weather
application because the iPad does not
come with a weather application you got
to download your own I like this one
called weather HD they actually animate
the weather conditions of any area you
punch in iPad apps are gonna cost a
little bit more money than iPhone apps
in general on average you're costing
between three to five dollars from what
we're seeing that's not too much and
fortunately you're still going to be
able to run all the iPhone apps that you
already bots